okay how does a hairy feel now only the
queen is allowed to call me so everybody
else Harry feel now that his hunch that
forest could exist would exist invade
has now recently been vindicated and
helps explain more about the diffuse
bands David Bradley well they haven't
actually got to the diffuse bounds yet
but I as i said earlier in the previous
question it's hard to believe that
they're not about that c6 is not
involved because if it's not involved
there there's something else out there
even probably more exciting and lurking
they're responsible for this and that
would be really exciting as well but by
and large the fact that it is there in
space is quite nice I I like that
because as I said the horizon program I
was pretty sure then that it must be
inspected I mean it has to be in
interstellar space but what I think the
most recent results indicated is that
there's a lot more than we expected my
friend might juror at UCLA made an
estimate now that from the camis work
and other people have also detected
material in space of c60 in space
there's about one percent of the carbon
which is amazing it really it's on and
so there you go there's more c60 around
them there is planet Earth there you go
it's a it's great I tonight obviously
very pleased in it and also that there's
so many exciting things to do in the
future it's a disk c where c 60 years
and to try to understand the way in
which c60 is involved in the
interstellar medium because it's got to
be made in in a star I don't think it
could be made in the interstellar medium
as possible it's got to be made at a
point where companies is nucleating very
rapidly and they always thought that are
called borealis stars RCB stars where
the place with a lot less hydrogen and
helium but you know some of these
objects have quite a lot of hydrogen and
that indicates that we really don't
understand carbon that well yet because
you would have expected that if there
was still a lot of hydrogen around that
carbon would go off in some other
direction but it looks like the
conditions and these stars even those
hydrogen as such that they favor c60 so
it's very exciting and obviously and I'm
quite satisfied with that last very
wrong at the end of that horizon program